I share a great appreciation for what's
been done before me and it's almost like
this it's reaching for the clouds you're
trying to constantly achieve something
that great within your lifetime and you
know you have to keep questioning
yourself and did I do that and I don't
think that's a thirst that's ever truly
quenched you know you you keep pushing
yourself forward and and wanting to
achieve something as great as as came
before you
you know you can't you can't stop
yourself from you know living the life
that you want to live and having
experiences that you want to have just
because of it you can't you know be
victimized by it you take the pros with
the cons and the pros are that I have
unbelievable opportunities now I'm going
to make the best of it
I think it's not just in human nature I
think it's a characteristic of all life
I think opportunism and greed is has
really been the key to uh you know
survival well the truth is it's you know
we all have good and bad in us you know
and that you know you have to stop
yourself
you have to stop yourself and you uh you
know ultimately need to create a balance
and and think about others It's a
combination of
being in the right place at the right
right time and being prepared for it and
and being aggressive about it and
sticking with it I'm not dependent on
this job you know I'm not this isn't
going to Define me you know and I
started to sell myself less prepare more
for the for the roles really investigate
the characters as much as I could and uh
not feel like you know my self-worth was
dependent on whether I booked a job or
not and I think that's finally what
clicked with me and I realized you know
every time I would sort of you know get
tired of the scene or not want to
persist you go pain is temporary film is
forever you go back in there and you
give it everything you possibly can
usually the first day is the most
nerve-wracking you know you've built
yourself up for all this preparation of
what you want this character to be and
you know that whatever you do the first
day or first couple days is gonna be
become a part of what this movie is and
a lot of times it's a learning process
while you make the movie to discover
what that character is so the first day
is always a very difficult one
I've always been fascinated by you know
this world that we live in and how
destructive we are to it and as soon as
I you know really became an actor that's
been you know a parallel passion of mine
is trying to bring attention to some
incredibly important issues I think that
really so little goes to protecting our
planet how we process bad news
and how it becomes a debate how truth
and facts can be distorted or
politicized
this was originally uh you know a
metaphor for the climate crisis if you
do a film about climate change this is
it it's nearly impossible to get people
to get a sense of urgency
and hold a mirror to our culture and
media and and and politics and all these
things and
we all know that reversing the course of
climate change will not be easy but the
tools are in our hands if we apply them
before it is too late
I believe that mankind has looked at
climate change in that same way as if it
were a fiction
as if pretending that climate change
wasn't real would somehow make it go
away
but I think we all know better than that
now
you know I've been I've been working
oh God since I was 13 years old and I
haven't aside from a year once I didn't
I haven't taken much of a break I'm
going to try to like uh
I guess take it if if it's good news
yeah I mean that's great I'll I'll take
it and uh make myself a better actor out
of it and I'm not going to change myself
as a person I think everyone can always
brush up on their technique it is you
know what we do is it takes a lot of
research or take I mean if you really
want to inhabit a role take so it takes
a lot of work and training and I think
it's incredibly important to constantly
no matter what how how successful you
are and I have to say is as long as
you're honest and authentic about your
portrayal of
who these people are no matter how
Despicable at times no matter what part
of you know the darker nature of
humanity you're exploring audiences will
always connect with that and go along
with that Journey with you and and
that's what I've found in my career and
the main thing you have to concentrate
on is doing your part and not worrying
about them worrying about you because
you're the character that you want to
make yourself look good on screen and if
you're too worried about and wrapped in
their business it's not going to work
out you just pick up things
automatically I mean I feel like I'm an
infinitely better actor than I was
before the film because of all the
things I've learned
I'll never get to really be young again
and this is my time to be young so if
there's roles right now that fit me as a
young person
I'm gonna do them and not sort of rush
into becoming the young adult I am a
young adult but like to be like the you
know
the sex symbol or this you know the
young guy
if I can do roles right now that are
young I'll never get a chance to do them
again and I plan on being around for a
while so
I'll get to do all that stuff later in
life I've sort of learned not to take it
so seriously and not to um
really give in to that not to be
depressed about it because I'm gonna get
to do what I want to get to do and
that's work and that's all that really
matters for me I think a lot of how a
lot of great movies and performances are
made when you know you take a chance and
try something different you know and
grow
as an individual and as an actor I
strive to be the best actor I can be and
whether I've achieved that is always you
know up to the audience and critics to
decide you can go into it with um the
best possible intent work as hard as you
possibly can
people for whatever reason may just
disconnect with the movie and that's and
you're powerless to that getting all
that emotion out of you and being angry
for three days at somebody and screaming
at them and punching them obviously
you're not gonna feel too hot afterwards
so it carries itself out but but you
know you gotta remember that pain is
temporary and films forever
being an actor is the first thing that I
remember wanting to do in life
um I remember it 14 15 years old
watching some classic films not well
spending months and months watching all
the great classics all the great
performers of the past and being so
incredibly inspired by them and saying
to myself one day I want to come close
to doing something that good so that I
think that that thirst or that drive to
just achieve what I believe is something
as good as those Heroes that I have is
what continues to make me want to uh
want to do this I think each person has
their own process you know whatever
works for them they should sort of do
I think I I still have that mind frame
like I said it takes a while to sort of
look at things for what they are and and
uh you know I still have the same
attitude thank God about what I want to
do career-wise which is to just you know
keep learning as an actor and trying new
things and
you know I don't want to get uh
stuck doing the same type of thing over
and over again I don't I need I mean
this is my life and I want to make it
exciting and especially in my career I
want to take chances
I took it down a notch
and I learned the valuable lesson that
some things are good only to a certain
degree I encourage you to watch the
history of Cinema
because as the history of Cinema unfolds
you realize that we all stand on the
shoulders of giants